[Music]
see my congratulations you just won
against federer parwana so tell us a
little bit about the key moments of the
game
yeah it was very end game and i thought
this position is obviously slightly
better but
i should be defensible i thought
h4 from fabi was not great because then
um my the difference is my hook is on f4
so ready to jump to d4 or maybe to the
queen side create weaknesses so it's
more active than on f5 and then i had
many plans i finally sacrificed this one
on e5
but then his king was under fire always
i got back the pawn and then
it just my hooks were always more active
than his works and he never had time to
create any sort of
of mating threats against my king
because then he would lose upon on each
force then it was just a matter of
technique i guess yeah actually his kid
was in danger it felt like why do you
think he just he went for this line or
he didn't have anything better at this
moment at this moment he already doesn't
have anything better because if he
doesn't take only five he goes king e7
then i go look c4 b6b4 and i assume i'm
much better so
because then i'm
crushing on on the queen side
probably there are still some chances to
defend i'm not really sure
but
in any case i would have been
considerably better
yesterday you showed the really inhuman
preparation against uh jeffrey song in
the game i saw this rook v8 i mean was
it all from preparation
actually no because uh instead of rb8
bishop e5 turns out to be stronger
i remembered some vibes
of things but
i couldn't remember the woodline
while everyone was playing in the
olympia with most of the players what
did you do
i was chilling mostly um
i actually
think i took some vacations i
don't even remember where but
like i know i was mostly in paris
just getting some rest uh
oh yeah yeah i went to south of france
uh got
a few a few days of uh
of chill and you know
uh just
you know we we're powering and you know
being uh
ready ended up to fight here yeah
actually so do you feel fresh after all
this time
um yes also because i i arrived early
also in the u.s i went to miami visited
some friends of mine and some good
friends there went to new york
afterwards so you know feels like
i'm
almost feeling at home